[Music]  are you not least with cylinder The Girl  with the Dragon Tattoo the girl who  hurts men I'm transferring all of your  cash it's your wife he won't hurt you  again  all those lucky ladies why did you help  everyone but me I've been told you're  the only person who can pull this off  that depends what am I looking for I  realized too late that I created an  abomination any want me to steal it for  you please help me someone  yep  [Music]  who's that  that's what I want to know  attract all of his ex associates every  single one leads back to one place home  for 16 years I've imagined this moment  this Basilica someone always has to  carry the pain now it's your turn  sister itself  she's been behind all of this  wherever she's planning it's bigger than  just you I know what just take apart  we're running out the time  now the world will burn  thank everyone  it was you who lit the match what you  thought shouldn't have a plan  [Music]  you